what's our poll question results as we
uh head into our third and final hour
here christopher
okay uh huge sports weekend coming up
what is the coolest thing
in sports to see in person
game seven buzzer beater no hitter
hail mary what do you have for me over
there chris so far no hitters at the
bottom
13 hail mary 25
buzzer beater 28 game
seven 34 fantastic yep
joining us now on the rich eisen show as
he always does
uh prior to a triple crown race love
this man
um going to give us some winners and a
winning ticket to punch for
the kentucky derby normally held the
saturday after the nfl draft it's held
the saturday before the nfl season
begins
hank goldberg the hammer back here on
the rich eisen show how are you hank
rich how are you i'm staying safe
i love it joe namath would say the
legendary handicapper from cbs
interactive and also espn uh joining me
here on the show hank you heard our poll
question about
uh game seven no hitter uh
hail mary and buzzer beater i assume you
have personally witnessed all four in
your
sports viewing lifetime hank
i think so yeah i'm not doing much since
the beginning of march except staying
home and
watching basketball and horse racing so
now i'm just wondering if you know
you've personally probably seen these
like in stadiums have you and you're
just in your life have you seen it have
you ever seen a no-hitter
oh yeah i saw the perfect game
the world series perfect game you were
at don larson's perfect game
you were there
actually i had mono and i was home from
school that day
so i thought okay i got it uh
all right but i i've seen no hitters
yeah
okay um but uh
no famous snow hitters but uh you've
been there yeah jeff
jeff torberg and i played uh baseball
together
in the maplewood twilight league and he
caught a bunch of no-hitters
so that's it's that's like a nice six
degrees of separation for jeff torborg
i love that hankover yeah that's my
connection fantastic all right let's get
into uh making people some money here
hank uh tis the law um the odds uh
three to five but i'm imagining uh once
the uh
race day hits tomorrow could he be even
worse what's your
what's your take on uh the uh derby post
positions the odds and how people can
make some cash this weekend
well the post positions have changed
they had another scratch today
okay and so now there's uh 16 horses in
the race
so there's nobody in the one hole and
they've all moved inside so
the outside horse uh is going to be
uh authentic and he's no longer in post
18 i think he's going to be in post 16
now which will help him it's being out
there isn't so bad right
now so that's a factor in the race
um i think there's a little bit of a
strategy
that's interesting with the outside and
that authentic is
either going to have to really gun it
with john velasquez because he needs the
lead
or since he and
you know he he's on one side of tis the
law
and you've got another veteran jockey on
the other side
and uh who's gonna be on
ap honor and those two veteran jockeys
could
try to shut off tis the law out of the
gate
talking about mike smith and if they do
that
they may sacrifice a little bit but
says the law has never had to come from
behind
very much and if they do decide to
try to take him out early on franco who
while he's a great jockey he's still
younger
uh it could affect the outcome of the
race but i think
yeah you're in it to win it and uh
and you know it's it's a you know it's
just a law
he is tell you an interesting story uh
when uncle chuck ran against him
and uncle chuck was a very highly touted
horse
and he was trained by baffert baffert
was watching the race with friends
and when uncle chuck had the lead since
the law
came alongside of him and bradford turns
to his friends and said
time to say uncle
and that would be the end of that so
what are your tickets you're gonna
what what ticket how are you gonna bet
tell us how you're gonna bet and how we
can make some money here
uh well our rights is the law okay he's
the best horse he's won his last three
races by
three and a half lanes or more it's the
sacatoga group
who've been down this road before uh
and uh he's uh i think he's simply the
best horse
so i've got him on top but i can't bet
him at three to five
so i've got him on top and superfectas
with uh i'll tell you a horse i like who
is 20 to one morning line uh and he's
out of the 15
and it's new york traffic okay this
horse doesn't get a lot of attention
but he's been second three times in a
row
in the haskell he uh almost
beat he almost beat
um the baffert horse
uh authentic and he
he stalks horses and he keeps running
second he was second in the louisiana
derby
second in the win in kentucky
and he was second in the haskell and he
was stalking
the baffert horse authentic and
he and he made a move on him in a
stretch
and the jockey on him thought he'd won
the race
if they'd have gone two more steps he
would have beaten authentic okay
this horse i think is going to hit the
board so i'm using him underneath
i'm using authentic underneath okay i'm
using
um let me use ap honor in there
and i'm going to use another baffled
horse who's in there
a thousand words who's out of the tent
post
okay a thousand words so i had to
disappoint a year early
but his late races have been better he's
training great
baffert really likes him and he's out of
the tent post
and i don't know how good he is
but baffert thinks he's very good and
that's so i'm going to throw him in
there underneath
so that's my superfeta and i'm going to
play exacto boxes
with you know the favorite and i'm going
to play him in one exacto
with new york traffic and i'm going to
play in x-acto box just in case
with tis the law and
new york traffic and i don't know how
good thousand words is
so let's say that uh they run one two
three
just for the heck of it okay that would
be that would be my bet
all right those exacted i love it hank
that's it i'm not
i'm not gonna use the other two
favorites okay that sounds like a great
uh advice chris brockman's
written it all down let's head to the
post and let's uh let's make some cash
before i uh let you go hank you got a
good tom seaver story any memories of
tom terrific who passed away at the age
of 75
this week got anything for me he was
just a wonderful guy
he he was as nice nice a guy as
everybody says he was
and he was the best met ever and of
course if you lived in new york area
which i did
and i saw him pitch a few times
he was great great in the clutch
you know he brought them a championship
and
he was probably one of the most popular
figures
in new york sports history i'm trying to
think of you know
outside of the yankee family
anybody who was more beloved than he was
and it's all true
yeah we put him up there with uh clyde
frazier namath
outside of the yankee family in terms of
new york sports um
yeah he's an all-time great um and i
just figured
i'd ask you about him um passed away at
the age of 75.
i didn't i didn't really know him very
well i had met him a couple of times
my sister had met him a couple of times
and
said he was just the perfect gentleman
always
i love it so he's
uh you know it's a tragedy it was that
you know he hadn't been well for a while
and
uh but boy could he pitch
sure i know he's incredible in a big
game
outside of whitey ford i didn't know a
pitcher who was better in new york in
the years i followed baseball hank you
take care of yourself stay healthy and
we'll we'll get in touch with you
uh before the preakness you know i gotta
say hello to susie
always she says hello to you too hank
you truly are
one of her favorites all time all time
you guys are the best
thanks right back at you thank you be
well you're safe stay
safe healthy and let's uh cash some
tickets